welcome to the endgame class December
23rd 2014 the theme of the endgame class
today will be pawn breakthroughs and if
you've watched other lectures here that
I've done in the endgame or any other
rotating resident Grandmaster probably
you remember we've talked about the idea
of creating past pawns in fact that one
of the only ways to win a minor piece
ending especially is by promoting a pawn
if you have a rook and pawn endgame or a
queen and pawn ending you don't
necessarily have to promote upon to win
because you can checkmate with the rook
or a queen but if you have a knight
ending like you see here it's unlikely
you'll checkmate with a knight if you
have a bishop ending the same thing so
it's pretty likely if you would like to
win you have to promote you to a queen
now if you have a past spawn then you
can push it and Queen it sometimes if
your opponent allows it or if it's
unstoppable if you don't have a passed
pawn you would like to create a passed
pawn so you can win now one of the
difficult problems when chess is that
when you learn things that you shouldn't
do you don't ever think about doing them
so probably somebody told you that
losing your queen is bad and you played
an opening you made a blunder your
opponent took your queen you were down a
queen and you lost and you were like man
I hope I never hang my queen again I
hate when that happens so when you play
end games often moves are good but you
discount them because they do something
bad and you're like oh I don't want to
do that that's bad when in fact the good
that it does is more important so in
some in games you'll sacrifice a piece
or you'll sacrifice a couple of pawns
and the goal is you're going to promote
to a queen and obviously if you can
Sacre
twice a night for example and promote to
a queen that's good for you but you
might not think of doing that because
you don't think of giving your pieces
away okay but in the endgame
it's so important to promote to a queen
you might have to think about a lot of
crazy stuff again this position it's
blacks turn to move the theme for this
lecture is going to be pawn
breakthroughs where in general the pawns
are blocking each other and you need to
eliminate your opponent's pawn so you
can make a queen and that might take
several sacrifices or several moves to
make now in this position on the Queen
side we can see that blacks three Queen
side pawns are blocked now blacks trying
to win for the very simple reason that
black is upon ahead so black has seven
pawns and white has six that's more
possible pawns that we can Queen also
black has more space blacks pawns are
moved further up the board okay I can
prove it by flipping the board confusing
everybody that's actually the same
position I just showed you but I flipped
the board so we can see that black has
three pawns on the fifth rank okay the
three that are highlighted in red and
white has zero so blacks pawns are
pretty close to promoting except they're
all blocked if your pawns want to
promote and they always do in the
endgame but they're blocked you have to
unblock them now the way for black to
unblock the pawns on the Queen side is
to remove some of the white pawns so the
first move is Knight takes Knight well I
thought it was okay I guess there is no
first move very confused why isn't it
working
nobody knows I would assume the moves
are there okay Knight takes Knight well
I guess the moves aren't saved okay
well I'll play the moves ender okay and
white plays pawn takes Knight and now
what have we done now we have three to
two on the Queen side so we have a
potential pawn breakthrough now before
we have our pawn break through
we better make sure that white isn't
going to Queen because that's also
important okay so we play King to f5 and
now d6 is a bit silly we just go take it
okay now if black could only break
through on the Queen side white would
just put his king there and that's the
end of the that's that's it okay
but luckily black has a monster pawn
majority on the Kings side black has
four pawns to three and whites pawns
can't move these pawns are sort of stuck
okay so basically white has to make a
decision now do I stop black on the
Queen side of the King side it seems
pretty obvious if you know white just
hangs around on the Kings side it will
play see four and we break and we break
through there's no way to stop the
b-pawn so let's say that white doesn't
see how black breaks through on the
Kings side and we'll just place King's
e2 and says well you you can't do
anything what are you going to do okay
now how does black break through on the
Kings side how does he make a passed
pawn
the H or very good okay now if black
played h3 that's that's pretty Queenie
so we have to take it
okay now this one pawn is stopping these
two pawns so black plays Matt g3
obviously we can't allow this and now we
can play either c4 or e3 I would play
see for myself okay and then III and
black has these two passed pawns and
White's King can deal with both of them
we just push them both and okay white
skin can stop one but you can't stop
both and whites blacks pawns I should
say are on the sixth and the fifth row
so they're pretty close to queening and
White's advanced pawns around the fifth
and the fourth row not as advanced the
other problem white has if white takes
one of the pawns while it's queening
then the other pawns going to queen with
check so let's try to Queen this pawn
okay and then we'll go check and then I
mean I would resign if I was white but
okay if you take this plunges Queens so
that was quick and if you stop the other
pawn then okay this pawn Queens and as
you can see you can't you can't stop
them both okay now in the game I think
white actually play King III to stop
with the puns on the you know this way
this way this pawn can't promote and so
black has to play C 4 and then b3
obviously we're threatening the Queen
now the King stops it then we do the
same thing okay so just a transposition
and since black spawns are on the sixth
rank and White's puns are not blacks
going to Queen much quicker than white
will and that's a pawn break through
that was started in the starting
position because black played Knight
takes d5 and after C takes it gave us a
chance to play c4 and b3 without that
black doesn't have any way to break
through on the Queen side unless he goes
a little crazy
and plays Knight takes a four but then
you'd be down at peace and this Knight
does a good job of stopping this e pawn
so it's much better to not sacrifice a
piece and here white has one pass pawn
but potentially black has two or three
passed pawns and they just can't be
stopped and even though black is losing
a pond or even two pawns a queen is much
more valuable
okay now more important than that well
the next position actually work so be
interesting well I actually be able to
make a move
okay well we'll find out I remember this
one too but okay here we have two pieces
for a rut and this is again the names of
each one in a simultaneous exhibition in
1921 although I'm assuming Matt Larson
would deny this was a Simon so well at
least yeah you got it okay so here again
it's hard to checkmate with a rook
against two pieces in fact I don't see
how blacks rook would even get in the
white position however black has many
more pawns than white so black has a lot
of chances to promote to a queen except
the pawns are all blocking each other we
need to do a breakthrough okay and this
makes the first move obvious that's a
breakthrough class so the first move is
yes before what
b4 is a fine move because it starts the
breakthrough yeah
now that and that's what he played very
good and White's like okay thank you
I'll take that and now what do we do how
do we continue to break through c3 is
actually a good move if that as long as
you play the sequence of moves that you
have to play you will break through
eventually he played rook takes Knight
c3 also works okay and obviously the
pawn has to take and now we have more
potential breakthroughs since we have
three potential breakthroughs plus we
have a pass point on g3 already there's
no way
White's going to stop all those pawns g3
blacks threatening g2
and then it's over so we have to take it
c3 as you suggested King takes c3 allows
King takes bishop so that's not good so
you take with the pawn and now a3 and
black has three passed pawns and the
bishop on seat on III can't you know go
to this diagonal and stop this pawn
because it's pawns in the way but even
if it could if we cheated somehow and
put this Bishop on a1 then f2 sewins
even by cheating you're not stopping the
puns so here this is a funny position
not only is white a piece ahead White
has more pawns than black but black
spawns are all in the 6th rank white
spawns run the 3rd and 4th rank so
blacks going to queen 2 or 3 moves
earlier extra queen is good and then we
wish to Dennis I'm all he was like hey
a3 passed pawn that sounds good now in
the opening you want to control the
center and play in the center so if
magically you could take off your side
pawns in chess you're a NH pawns and
your opponent took off their center
pawns they're E&D pawns you would be
very happy because you're going to
control the center immediately and your
opponent can't do that he has no Center
pawns the endgame it's sort of the
opposite if your pawns are on the side
and one piece is supposed to stop them
both that's not going to happen but if
you have pawns of the center connected
then the King can stop them both a
bishop can of knight can and here since
blacks pawns are pretty far spread out
there's just no way the King and Bishop
can stop them and I think quite resigned
here yeah okay I think the a pontius
Queens Kings c1 which does stop the a
pawn hangs the bishop but if it's in to
hang the bishop you'd still win because
you have all these pawns so yeah you're
still you're still getting the Queen
okay although taking the bishop would be
easier yeah so three passed pawns all
across the board it's over but let's go
back and look at that that was pretty
cool b4 started it off you can play C 3
here if you want rook takes
g3 you have to take on g3 the way G to C
3 a 3 and that's it okay with so many
arrows what chances does white have not
much and that's good because if I wanted
to I could just set up positions that
are sort of known but they've never
happened and then I would show you like
breakthroughs but it's better when you
actually see it in a game because it's
unusual that you get to see what you
learn in practice and put it into
practice especially in a simulcasted to
do that ok this is pretty funny
in fact if then Simon was here he would
find it even funnier that this isn't
working out so well ok that was easily
fixed
ok let's flip the board or no yes ok so
what I lived in Europe which actually
was this game was played around the time
I moved back one of my favourite players
was tomas ernst or as he was called
tomas the Hitman ernst ok arjun gets
that now Ernst was a funny guy in a lot
of ways but in this game he has a
completely drawn position against the
Russian Grand Minister Andre Karloff and
the ratings are about the same and
there's almost nothing on the board I
guess if it was King versus King it
would be easier but ok each side has
three pawns naturally nobody should win
this black should just chill out and
keep his King in front of the C pawn and
White's King can't really go to the
Kings side because because there's
nowhere to go like those squares are all
covered by pawns and your King can't run
into check although maybe in some
scholastic tournaments ok so so this
should be a draw as computer says but
instead after the move King III Tomas
bata moves that loses instantly and if
you're taking notes don't do that ok
naturally yes or his lectured on this
before I think he calls it because he
somebody else said it
the Icelandic breakthrough unless I miss
remembering which is 50/50 game and
actually I've done this mainly in blitz
games I might have done it in a
tournament once but it's pretty cool
breakthrough and since this is a
breakthrough class that seems like a
good idea just show breakthrough so
computer says that King d6 should lead
to a draw because white doesn't have any
way to break through on the Kings side
although I could see why you wouldn't
want to play King g6 and let White's
King go forward I would see where you'd
want to keep your King on e5 solid then
White's King can draw so black played
the more or less obvious move g5 and
then he should have resigned next move
but he didn't resign he maybe he did
resign now he didn't gay probably too
embarrassed okay
and now White has a passed pawn on the
Queen side right he'd like to have a
passed pawn on the Kings side and I
don't think blacks King can move in both
directions that would be my opinion okay
and here white made a very unusual move
which which as I said yes or has
lectured on before which he's also done
so White's a move in win it's a one
movie answer ken west g4 Matt Larsen
approved okay g4 now both sides are
going to get passed pawns on the Kings
side except white as a passed pawn the
Queen side too so that's not good
Black has two moves that makes sense he
could just take either pawn if you takes
H pawn then I'll take the H pawn and
blacks King has to stop these two pawns
I don't think that's possible and
White's King has to stop these two that
seems much easier see we just know that
was it that was easy right this is the
stop okay
so black played now black obviously
didn't see g4 or he wouldn't have played
g5 I'm assuming after g4 he was very
embarrassed because he is a grandmaster
and he has to resign now in a dead drop
position so
I think he played on several moves just
to make the game go longer so he took on
g4 and let's somebody else raise their
hand ken west answering every question
Julianne h5 right and we have the two
outside pawns Black has more pawns than
white but black spawns are all together
so my King goes in front of them yo
don't do that that makes noise right
okay what white spawns are far away so
what black needs to play bog house and
put a piece in front of one of the pawns
okay so black played four tricks but
that didn't work out okay he might even
check him again okay and after age seven
he realized he's a bit too slow yeah he
could play f3 chat he resigned here but
okay you're the eye queen and yeah your
pawns not cleaning yet okay so that was
pretty funny because after maybe
obviously just didn't see g4 and this
idea where both sides get a passed pawn
sometimes works and sometimes doesn't
hear of course it works because White's
King is very close to the queening
square and all of blacks pawns are
concentrated on one side your King can
stop pawns on one side but not on both
so again if this was an opening or a
middle game this would be a favorable
pawn structure to black because white
would have an isolated pawn and black
has perfect pawn structure but here
because it's an endgame now White has to
pass pawns
there's no pieces on the board so
they're just going to queen
so g4 was a very nice catch by Karloff
and the only thing I wonder is that
Ernst realized this mistake before after
Karloff played g4 it's a just a terrible
feeling when you're sure the game is
going to be a draw than after g4 you
have to resign that's unfortunate then
these positions are fun to look at with
the chess engine because chess engine
says zero zero zero zero draw then you
make a move like g5 and then explodes
then the red light comes on and
nonces maid says +40 pretty funny okay
but okay well you're a human you make
those kind of mistakes
occasionally okay now this is a funny
game because I didn't know it beforehand
and it was just it was very badly played
so this is kappa blanka playing Edward
Lasker in 1913 it says casual so wasn't
a tournament now I met Edward Lasker
unlike most of you I met him in 1979 in
Montreal at the Montreal tournament and
that was a very strong tournament course
I was still being blacklisted by the
Soviets right Julien so there was a
question I didn't play because otherwise
the Soviets wouldn't have played and the
organizers like this Soviets are pretty
good so the players were Karpov tall
Spassky poor dish Tim on Lubavitch kaval
ik and Larson unless I said Larson
already maybe he played twice cuter play
those eight players double round-robin
tied for first tall and Karpov with 10
out of 14 pretty good score I was there
when Larson B Karpov was black that was
I was only there for three days or so
and I met Edward Lasker he was you know
it is his early 90s okay now don't
confuse Edward last or the Manuel Lasker
I'm sure you were doing that
Arjen was like I was doing that okay and
then our just said who write have you
heard of either one of those players see
there you go but probably a manual asker
probably yeah there you go now a lot of
people think they were related they
definitely were not brothers but I think
they found out later in life they
thought they were not related but maybe
they were okay very suspicious they were
distant cousins but they treated Bill
Murray like a fourth cousin okay and
also they like cheeseburgers okay
now Edward Lasker was a bit suspicious
compared to the world's best player he
is okay
he was probably strong iron strength
although if you look at the
scam you may disagree okay so last
replayed King to d5 and now the mistakes
started to happen I will blame it on
casual chests okay when I play casual
chess every move is a mistake and the
moves I didn't play that I was
considering are also mistakes now in
this position it's clear to even the
most dim-witted individual with an
advanced degree in hyperbolic topology
that black is in zoogs Wong right Arjen
see okay so white wants to make a queen
on the Kings side white has three pawns
to two well black can't play King e6
here because you're hanging your d4 pawn
if you don't want to hang your d4 pawn
you're going to play king c5 but you're
not going to play king c5 is not going
to make a queen you see what I'm saying
so black actually can't move here so
having said that the winning move would
be pretty hard problem kappa blanka
couldn't find it so a3 very good
computer recommended +8 million
okay and now if a5 obviously a for that
black can't move black plays king c5 now
we start the cleaning process okay and
black tries to get back but yeah you can
you can't catch the point okay so Kappa
blanket could have won quite easily by
playing a three but instead he blundered
which is good for us because then Laster
blundered and it's funny
okay casual game casual okay so 83 wins
kappa blanket played f5 he thought he'd
win quicker and he did so okay
in obviously Lasker took and kappa
blanket played h5 okay and now last we
made the losing move this is actually a
draw this position except he made a
really bad move and resigned so that
didn't work out very well so actually
there's another zoogs long and Lasker
fell into it um
okay so if it was white to move g6 would
win okay so black has two possible moves
that stop g6 winning King e6 and kicky 5
and you actually to do some analysis to
figure out which is right either he
didn't do any analysis or he analyzed it
wrong I don't know okay
he played the obvious move which one's
more obvious a 5 or e6 he said who says
II 6 who says he 5 okay the people said
he 5 were correct
it's more obvious but it's terrible yeah
your move is better okay
the reason is after king e5 which was
played in the game kappa blanka played
the only move that wins and if i may may
I
if he doesn't play the only move that
wins he loses so this is thought you can
answer quick we talked about this in the
lesson okay
white has one move that wins there are
no moves that draw and otherwise black
wins so you can see that Lasker is like
hey maybe I'll win okay what is the only
winning move for Wyatt a3 what do you
say uu what's that
a3 and Julian will give the right answer
right which is sort of the mirror image
yeah okay so h6 and I don't if you
resigned here yeah he resigned okay now
white wants to play g6 with advantage
because it Queens okay and then that's
it like there's no defense to that so
that was easy any legal move black plays
white plays g6 and then he Queens so the
game ended okay now so that wasn't good
analysis by Lasker because that age six
resigns so remember Edward Lasker not a
manual as okay so let's look at key e6
just let's prove for giggles now h6 III
stop that you see what I'm saying yeah
now blacks all happy okay okay and after
the move King takes d4 which was not
legal after king e5 maybe that's my last
replay King e5 now blue
that tries to make a queen highly
recommended by me and if he doesn't he
could resign so he makes a queen and why
it's like no you don't he's like yeah I
do
and why it's like I and then and then we
go here okay so if White doesn't want to
lose we'll play g6 and h6 is a draw and
taking as a draw either way on let's
take just to show and even though white
wins this pawn it's a draw and black
makes these two moves for the next
thousand moves okay
and if black is allowed to play king b8
that would be good if white doesn't
allow that White's king is going to go
to a seven and a eight that's hard to
Queen when you're Kings on e7 in a hit
okay but otherwise blacks play is very
easy okay you make the same to lose a
million moves in a row see you good and
if somehow black white plays king b6 we
just come in here okay so that was a
draw if you play King e6 and also White
was just completely winning by playing a
three here because then black blacks
King on d5 is perfect
he's defending his pawn he can't go to
e5 if he goes to c5 now this
breakthrough works so a3 just easy win I
think even if you let your engine sit
for a minute announce his maid does 83
and like mated 24 or something but then
it says it says FIV draw okay and then
he didn't play King e6 that he lost but
after king e5 if you see the move h6
you'll be like wait a minute I can't
stop those plans okay maybe he didn't
see h6 I don't know although if he
didn't see h6 then he would have thought
he was winning because now blacks
winning otherwise white really can't do
anything else so a very strange play by
both players and King e6 is sort of a
weird move because we're giving our pawn
away but at least we're stopping white
from queening which is more important if
you have a choice of giving away upon or
letting your opponent promote you a
queen
that's no dis
to paraphrase Reservoir Dogs that's
really paraphrasing that's the most
right right Arjun yeah that's that's a
lot of paraphrasing okay if it's either
them or me that ain't no decision so H 5
kg 6 is a draw a king e5 loses now most
of my students especially the ones in
this room when they're in an endgame and
it's incredibly complicated they move
instantly that because they play perfect
right now the end games are very
difficult and occasionally one move wins
one move draws and one move loses and
taking 10 or 15 minutes would lead you
to the right move by doing a small
calculations and four players of this
ilk
they shouldn't play moves like King e5
losing in one move they should play King
e6 and try to draw and after King e6 he
but is still lost because he still has
to find out for here if he just does
nothing and let's White's King come in
then okay and he's going to lose but f4
f3 f2 and the King goes to f5 and it's a
draw and again the most important thing
is not letting your opponent queen-like
deployed on g4 isn't worth very much
it's much more important to stop white
kappa blanka had no problem at all
giving up on away he was trying to Queen
although he could have been a little
more foxy and played a three but okay it
was a casual game somehow it was written
down everybody knows about it so well
you guys play casual games they're
taking notes that okay but those players
work we're quite good okay this was also
played in a game and actually it's sort
of like a puzzle but it was an actual
game and I was like well there's no
answer here because I looked at it for
like one second so my analysis was
perfect and so instead of solving the
problem in two minutes which I probably
should have done I just said a probably
the answer is wrong that they're giving
and then I saw the answer I'm like oh
yeah good the reason this is a bit more
complicated than the previous puzzles is
because this is two breakthroughs okay
so well why
obviously going to breakthrough on the
kingside because I don't think this pawn
is going to break through this pawn that
seems unlikely however on the kingside
White has four pawns to three and the
most obvious continuation after f5 which
threatens e6 winning is to take and then
e6 wins and that's like pretty simple
then this pawn is going to Queen so it
takes g6 okay
and after f5 what obvious move to
prevent the breakthrough does black play
because you don't want to break through
ecigs
right and I was like what kind of puzzle
is this they probably didn't even see e6
okay but obviously I looked at the
puzzle for one second if I had looked a
little longer I would have seen
breakthrough number two okay and
breakthrough number two is even better
than one sort of like diehard no can wes
is like what argent you explain that to
him ah what not as explained hot die
hard choose better than one very unusual
which godfathers better the first one
anybody agree probably not right you
agree Wow Arjuna case huh yeah I don't
know if Arjun to back that up
alright Arjun how do we break through
again I didn't see that that might work
there there there there there
they hold on hmm he might be right as
Jim Tarzan once said to an audience when
I suggested a crazy answer I'm afraid
he's right although I'm not sure you're
right hold on ah sold yeah you're not
right not nothing against you good job
but I think I can defend you know how I
defend I don't take your F pawn so here
you go here I calculated right it could
be embarrassing
here f4 okay it's the diamond formation
king CA and now I ignore you
King d8 you see what I'm saying and then
I think I'm okay I think my Kings close
enough right
what was i right really what White Sands
looks Wong
how about King b12 a to forever right
who promotes how does black promote oh
yeah yeah draw I agree okay so you were
close but since you're too young no
cigar
oke six and how long six almost work I
thought he had a duplicate answer I was
getting scared for a second okay but why
you actually found the right move in the
game and/or moves jewels naughty six
there's no difference okay so you take
one of the pawns and now we play argent
style right Arjun okay f4 f5 remember
okay
f5 now the black king is pretty close to
the white a pawn but it's not too close
to the other pawns so the only try for
black is is e takes because you played G
takes I'm relatively sure this thing
going to catch that okay but he takes
maybe we'll catch it and we can't let
them play this either because you can't
catch that okay and then why it's very
lucky because it's a puzzle and then
here there was an actual game alright
and that's all she wrote that if you
have a lot of style then you promote to
a rook okay because I don't know why
exactly yeah if you have great
calculating powers you may get a bishop
bishop g6 Bishop d3 and then you barely
win if you win at all maybe that's a
draw think it's a draw yeah
like so yeah look it's a draw so don't
do that
yeah you look cool but you won't win
yeah okay so yeah after after have five
blacks like no breakthrough for you and
then why it's like now I got another
pawn so I got two pawns one for each of
you no nothing no tombstone okay you at
home you got it okay yeah you know I'm
talking about okay now uh where's new
board come on Ben Simon okay if you say
so
now where's new board control end all
right
the audience is spoken all right now how
do I get a new like empty board I don't
believe that clear board okay now the
most famous pawn breakthrough that's not
a real game but it's you know like the
one that you've all learned before class
that's funny okay is this one and it's
so common to learn this that actually
exactly half of you know it raise your
hand if you know this position it's
exactly half right look look at them
just say it is doesn't matter if it's
and even at home like half are raising
their hand
eight million or raise their hand eight
million are like okay okay now I had a
student in Michigan who we won't name
and he used to teach chess to little
kids and this was one of the positions
he showed and he showed them how to
break through they're like yay
okay then he had this in a tournament
not the exact position but the same
breakthrough then he didn't do it and
after the game he was like I could have
played b6 I've been teaching that for 20
years but he didn't do it there was like
another some other stuff on the Borba
jan matter just be some same thing
okay so this is a breakthrough that you
should learn before you learn the other
ones but it's his other way around
okay white plays b6 white has two
threats
okay black takes one way now this one's
almost home but this pawn is stopping
him so c6 now that's the threat
and then we clean our pond and of course
black could have taken with a see pawn
which you didn't do and now a six and we
Queen the C pawn and that's a well-known
pawn break through what's not as well
known is that if you had black in this
position and it was your turn how would
you stop that break through and a lot of
people suggest moves that don't do very
well
they suggest moves that lose immediately
that's not the right answer
okay so let's play King here to make it
black some of what a chess teacher okay
now black has three possible pawn moves
okay if you play a six White has one
move it wins who can find it whites
winning with a pawn break through as we
learned in this class Arjun close if B
six I don't think you're going to break
through right that's what he meant
C six now it's all now it's all over
right I'm going to Queen some pawn and
the reason my breakthrough works and
yours doesn't because basically we're
both breaking through here is because I
like tony robbins and you don't know
that's not why okay I mean Arjun left
more than anybody okay and if you got
that joke very suspicious
all right the reason is White's pawns
are very close to queening White's pawns
are on the fifth and sixth row blacks
pawns on the second and third row that's
not good so see six runs into the same
issue a six and again White's breaking
through however there is no break
through against b6 there's no way that
white can make a queen
unless black makes a mistake so if I
take this way taking back this there
would be a mistake
but you would just maintain the pawns in
front of each other and this would be a
draw okay and so black to move b6
White's it move b6 easy to remember the
answer now Julian is probably thinking
king g6 and can I stop the pawn what
else could he be thinking you can't
anything anything else right
so you mean even though it's White's
move your move over buck what move are
you playing now right and after we keep
taking it's White's move now I started
taking first it has to be my move
no like I take then you take then I take
then you take this my move right but if
it was your move let's cheat okay let's
play like Julian but sheet and Julian's
like if it was my move let's make it his
move I'm winning except he's not winning
okay but you wanted to be winning you
were like blacks losing without blacks
winning okay but this is a draw because
opposition and such right not the point
of our lecture I'm sure all of you could
draw this position King anywhere
well King h3 loses a king h1 I would go
here for being funny okay although I
would go to g3 just in case I don't be
too funny okay and then okay if somehow
it was black to move and black got to
take this pawn he's still in that
winning because King b3 is the
opposition which isn't really the point
of our lecture but so funny
okay so b6 wins if it's White's move b6
draws of it's blacks move that sort of
makes it easy to find the right move
with b6 okay and if h6 is played by
anybody or c6 that's terrible c6 buy
black loses because of a6 and the pawns
break through you want to make sure your
opponent's pawns don't break through
because if you're both trying to Queen
White's going to Queen first by at least
two or three moves so that's not good
for black then you have to help your
opponent can't mate with a queen
unlikely okay that's the standard break
through that you first learn and then
you can go to other breakthroughs you
just have to see that three pawns don't
necessarily stop three pawns four pawns
can also break two against four and so
on
sometimes the pawn structure is blocked
and there is no break through and
sometimes there's a breakthrough when
your opponent captures but you just
don't capture so
sort of hoping for a capture but the guy
just sort of chills so then you know you
can't do anything okay so this is a win
for white if it's White's move it's a
draw other wise and the advantage again
the white has is white spawns are closer
to Queen if you are playing for a
breakthrough in a King and pawn endgame
the main reason you're doing so is your
pawns are further advanced okay your
pawns are on the fifth row and your
opponent's pawns around the second row
or your pawns are on the fourth row and
those are on the third row then if the
pawns both get to promote to a queen
you'll promote first if it's further
advanced right Arjen agreed okay so I
hope you like the breakthrough lecture
if you never liked our lectures before
and you like this one well that's a real
breakthrough
you